what do you think about that uh block of
its fight
in atasana i'm gonna go with adasanya
just because
i mean i i think honestly i i mean
blockovich definitely has power bro like
that's different
and arasana is going up a weight class
he's going up a weight class to 205.
so what can happen when you go up a
weight class what what are some things
that can happen
not even specifically to them but what
are some things that could be
good or bad uh i mean the bigger animal
it's like the law of nature the bigger
animal usually beats the
the littler animal um but i think uh
so that's kind of a little bit of a
natural kind of pitfall
yeah i mean there's weight classes for a
reason like uh
if someone has 30 pounds on me and
they're
you know not nearly as good as me you
know they have a better chance against
someone who's my weight for sure you
know just because they're bigger you
know right they could lay on you and
hold you down yep and it's harder to
move them like i think that there's two
types of strength
in jiu jitsu this might help you a
little bit too but there's
the type of strength where i can move
you really easy and then there's the
type of strength where
i make it so you can't move me very easy
there's those two types of strength and
um at my weight i can move people you
know
but if someone's 30 pounds heavier than
me like it's i
you know i can't move them as easy and
like that makes things a little bit
harder so yeah
yeah so that's one thing but uh i think
i think that
that dude has different level of power
that
i think israel is not dumb enough to
overlook you know i think that israel is
like a super smart dude and i don't
think he i don't think he's gonna
leave any stone unturned or like lie to
himself in his head like i see people do
that all the time in fighting just
because i
like going back to the ego stuff like
i'll see them say some stuff where i'm
just like
you're only saying that because it helps
you sleep at night
you know like oh this guy's slow or oh
this guy can't grapple it's like
man you're only saying that so you could
feel a little bit better about yourself
right
and i noticed that right away you know
uh
israel i don't notice that in you know
where israel doesn't
he's not like oh this guy is slow it's
like or no he doesn't have power he like
acknowledges the strengths in the other
person and i think that that's
a really obvious sign that like the
person
is intelligent you know i think it's
really unintelligent to just overlook
everything
that you're that your opponent has that
they do well and just create an excuse
for it yeah but i think israel's smart
enough man and i think he has enough
experience and i'm sure that he's had
plenty of fights
in kickboxing where he's fought really
big dudes too that like we have never
even heard of because the dude has like
a million kickboxing fights especially
in new zealand
yeah everybody there is a pretty big
dude
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices some guy just brings you one
option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one